He's going to die anyway. I'm sorry but let's get killed right now. Oh. My
Oh my God. Walking Dead. Episode three it's out the
episode that wasn't supposed to come out. The company just goes bankrupt out of
nowhere and everyone is freaking out. How did this happen. Oh my God.
But here we are anyway. They managed to do it somehow.
I don't know how this is gonna be this. This might be a total shit
fest it just hit me.
I'm very thankful to the people that pulled through to get this done for the
fans. It seems like that's the case here. You know the company has gone
bankrupt anyway so
Really big ups to everyone that worked to get this done. Episode 4 as we can see
is gonna come out as well in March 26 SO WE'RE GONNA GET THE CONCLUSION OF
CLIMATE times destiny and there's no reason for me to keep waiting. Start now.
Yeah. They have they're another poor game design choice.
Just kidding. There's no reason for me to the walking dead while searching for
a place to call home.
Aj and I found an old boarding I got fuel inside of here.
Deep in the forest. Their leader was a guy named Marlin
and agent equaled the trigger.
Yeah. Thanks A.J.. Thank you very much. I told you a haircut and you just shot
him in the face that he'd have to atone for it.
The other kids agreed. They voted to kick us out.
I thought we'd never return.
Then five minutes passed and we were back tracked by Abel one Ireland had given
the twins too. He was with someone I thought I'd never see again.
Obama Lily. Oh God.
We were almost eaten by walkers when suddenly one of them spoke to me. They
can talk about James an owl whisperer who didn't believe in killing walkers.
He helped me treat AJ but without real medicine he wouldn't make it.
The kids didn't turn away sad side of AJ and let us back inside
after I told them how we could defend the school against the Raiders. They were
willing to let us stay at least until the fight
I decided to help fight what happened that looked at the stars together. Violet
is a friend. Those are rare savage jungle raiders from Gavin. They
busted open our gates but the kids stayed hidden as planned until 10 ran out of
cover hoping for a chance to learn about his missing sisters.
The bomb went off in attempting to save 10. Mitch threw himself at Lily and got
a knife to the throat. Good timely a second to decide.
I fired and saved Lewis. You're welcome Lewis. They got away with three of our
friends and we had no idea at all. Oh but we knew someone who did.
Ok. This will be interesting to say the least. Oh
man. Jesus Christ. I figured they would have already started on Episode 3 when
they went bankrupt and everyone had to leave but I don't know really like
anything about that.
Already these games are kind of wonky already. Like there's some pretty funny
bugs that appear here in there
So I'm really curious just how this will affect the quality. I mean.
That looks pretty good. Thanks for that Alex. I mean I'll take it. They might not.
He's just frozen solid. I guess his rigor mortis. You could blame it on. It.
Sorry I need to stop looking at everything through this lens.
The story was so little and
Looked out for me. People said he was a dick sometimes. But he was
always nice to me. Because you're a pussy that we've got
Stabbed in the eye by some asshole who never even knew his name.
Let's go for revenge. I promise you will. The people who did this. We're going
to hit them back. They're gonna regret ever coming near us. Yeah. Why not. If
Mitch were here he wouldn't cry. He'd find a way to get our friends back.
That's right. BASH The least brains out with a rock.
Can't waste tied up in the basement. He passed out from the pain. Thanks. AJ wanted to stay down there and keep an eye on it.
Hey buddy. It's time for us to bury Mitch and say our goodbyes. I hope you don't wait for me.
The reason he's dead. Yeah I was too. We had a plan and I had messed it up.
Be nice even if it's true. Look I know even if it's true you can't lash out. Oh
God your ugly hair of each other.
You think it's true.
Oh. I. I. Oh. Oh that came out wrong.
Talk to Abel. See if you can't find out where Lily took Vi. Omar Anderson.
Well I'm already making all the wrong choices. This will be great. I can't wait
to read the comments. I just couldn't. Maybe you'll get more out of him than I did
Careless go down and check on him. Great.
Oh I'm wants my attention. Anger please. I'm playing video games. All right.
Oh never mind interrogate Abel. Okay. All right Mr. Dog.
I've got some questions for you. Where are the money. Huh. Where did you put
the money Mr. Abel.
Huh. Look at the bloodstains. All right Detective Clementine
must be grapefruits.
All right. Spell it out Rosie. Oh she teleported
Oh Rosie doesn't trust you yet Rosie. What do you want to like play a video
game so we can bond a little bit.
Oh my God. He's actually crazy.
I don't like those ice that tape does not look tight enough.
Ready shoot him in the dark.
Fuck it.
God everyone is so ugly. Ain't no way to wake an old man up from his
afternoon nap.
I was having a nice dream too about a girl I used to know from before.
She also had me tied up but I wouldn't her prisoner if you get my meaning. Oh
hell yes bro face.
New water that joke. You actually actually get to meet that you got good man or squirt.
I think I made the wrong choice.
I think I'm gonna get the bad and now you've had your water. You know it's time
to talk is the first time interrogating someone in that you let me
dictate the agenda. Makes me think you're weak.
Don't even like dog like that.
Hey I just want to know where Lily took my people. It doesn't matter
As soon as she gets there she's gonna turn around and come right back for me to
give me the fresh start treatment. If I'm smiling when she gets here you
might be able to trade me for a little mercy. We underestimated you little
shits but Lily won't make the same mistake twice.
I mean I think he's right. We'll do it again. Yeah.
Don't doubt a surprise. Didn't record you know how to scrap.
Now we know. Just tell us where they took our friends so we can get them back.
Then what.
They will never give up. Only reason we came here was for more manpower.
Losing Jonathan MI 3 sprouts can barely hold a gun
Maybe the waistband will help us actually do that or did happen.
You don't know what it's like out there. It's a bloodbath. One community against
another from Richmond to the coast. Back in the Delta we're at war with some
really sick fucks who make me look like the Virgin Mary. We need people to
fight it. Soldiers who do what we say. Point the guns the way we tell them
to you little turd is supposed to be easy pickings.
Kidnapping you can't just take whatever name you want.
I call it survival.
What kind of place is this Delta if they use forced labor to defend it.
You think we like doing raids like this. Yes. Home is under threat.
It's a good home built to last.
Do a lot to protect it. Maybe you can understand that.
And I do a lot to get my friends back so stop wasting my time
OK.
Front pocket answered all your questions.
You didn't search him already.
Read it.
Whatsoever part of the possible meme incoming footed.
Never mind the cud among the beasts that shall you eat. What the fuck is this code.
No it's fucking love it. Clementine. Please don't swear.
Hope hoping will be some timely moralistic shit about turning the other cheek
welcome on that thing and going to light itself or
smoke I'll clear my mind.
He's actually. Oh my God. Where did I go. Oh my God. Remember stuff.
Vern Hendley went down kid.
Fuck it. I don't really care. Here. Hit it. Hit it.
Hit it man is heavenly.
Oh my God. That's what was in that joint dude.
This is good.
He's gonna die. I love that you try and do something nice for someone and they
merely cough up blood. I will patch him up if I
Catch you look man. Patch him up.
I don't think so. We can cover up that bald spot. Don't worry about it. Shoot
the moose to burst inside of me. No medicine could fix this all.
I never want things to end like this. Everything
got out of hand.
Oh fuck it best only time. No.
Yeah I think that's a yes. My whole life. Everything I ever got.
I got my own two hands and I will from my
body the dirt on me that they could throw I'll
tell you where to find Lilly. Just promise you won't let me touch her.
Hey. Okay. We got yourself a deal there. Listen ball man. I'm begging you. All
right. You have my word. Which means I'm locked in this universe.
I'll put you out of your misery.
You have my word okay.
We have a boat. We're docked a few miles west of here. Had an old fishing beard.
Your friends are on the boat.
Oh look at that. They're on the boat. Excellent.
You go and you walk. Don't let me go.
Oh where and where where I am. Okay. Well are you turning on ready
dialysis treatment.
All right. Shoot him in a decade you know that.
Let me keep my face.
I wouldn't worry about your face as I was your buddy. If I were you. Okay. I
want you to see this. What the fuck psychopath you need to watch this. I want
to. Well he he's already a psychopath. Great. You'll make a great YouTube.
All right. So let's just aim for like this area.
Okay to say oh I did it anyway. Or you just cut his throat or something. Oh.
How is that better. How is that better. I got a shot in the face.
At least you can't hurt anyone anymore. Shut up AJ
That was not mercy. That was disgusting.
Come on we have a boat to find. Why would you yell
Aj. Stop. You're freaking me out AJ. Stop it. Stop. AJ Stop
it. AJ. AJ.
Skype. Oh I'm not. Skip this. Okay. Last time I got a compromise right. Because
this god damn menu.
I am just gonna sit through it.
Once we find the boat we'll look for a way to sneak onboard. Yeah Ted doesn't
fuck it up this time.
A ten can do it if he wanted to transport. Yes Thanks A.J.. Mitch died because
say one more thing about a dare you
Guys. Oh there it is.
So who did they kidnap again. They kidnapped the girl and was there anyone else.
Okay. They got a boat
Fitzgerald. You see anything.
The beach a boat and a wood Street. Thanks A.J. and
proven yet again that you're Sarah. I assume. Jesus Christ. Okay let's spread
out. Focus on those areas.
Lift your heads low.
I like how with Oh my God. Forgetting
everyone's names I'd like a word with Clementine.
You know the main thing that she was taught by the character in the first game
was to cut her hair so that she wouldn't get hurt. And now she takes care of
another person. And he has a goddamn afro.
Probably the easiest thing you could grab I have horses I'm sorry but
am I the only one saying this.
Okay so they have like torches. Oh I see torches. No I think it's a stick with
fire on the easy fire. Good joke setting hay on fire would get their attention
scared and then the horse is on fire on the boat and you see my bombs.
Yeah. I like that horse is free. Could slow down anyone trying to chase us.
I'm sorry but if there were zombies out and about how can you just leave horses around unprotected.
Oh that's right. I'm right about everything. No way.
Pretty sure I would've remembered an old timey riverboat from where I'm sitting.
Looks like that pier is the only way inside.
Well let's see what else is down there. OK. So we have like a box here.
The pier has plenty of cover on it. If we're careful we can sneak in undetected.
Mm hmm. I like that idea. I can see an entrance.
Yeah there's one at the other end of the boat too. There's a small opening at
the top of those closed doorways and I know how to deal with those.
And so do I. Bye bye. Bam sex joke obvious place to keep prisoners don't boats have. Briggs
Boat jails maybe where. Now that I I don't know.
There are a few on deck. Couple others on the pier could be more inside.
Right. I see. I like Holy shit. This is really it.
We found them incredible job guys. All right.
What else do I need to look at here.
The path. There's no good cover leading up to the boat.
We can do better right. Hell of a distraction. Snake Snake tactics six crawl.
I'm really got some base.
Some of the shooting really well.
Oh you look so funny with the binoculars. Now we just need what a dozen walkers.
How hard could that be. Easy.
He's not as hard as you think.
Okay so now we go right. All right. Do I talk to you. Talk to Willie. Really.
What are you even looking at. Like the boat is over here.
Such a bowl full of bags. Man anything useful but not building material
furniture. Probably stuff from the train station
okay. Well you can't talk properly anyway I down quite a bit of it. Should have that stop.
I like I like you're thinking Willie. I changed my mind. Do they have torches
Torches torch. Oh my God. This change your fire. Oh yeah.
I said it before they did it. This raft with supplies I could cut those loose
and try them down river. Easy. Oh my God.
Sorry really but you're like super duper smart. We should get out of here
before they spot us.
We can talk to the plan once we're somewhere safe okay.
Little disappointed that I didn't ever use the snake tactics but I'll let you
get that one strong go grass covering the streets.
All right. What's the plan.
They've got guards posted on the pier and the boat. There's no way we can take
them all at once. Our only hope is to distract them while we sneak and make a fire.
You release the horses.
That work. We could burn the supplies or the hay they keep for the horses.
Whatever we don't burn we should take Ruby and love to have the horses but I
rather steal the supplies. I could build traps. I would rather use that. I
would rather use it. We'll take the horses and we can. Yeah. This is how she's
like a horse whisperer. The fire will lure the readers away from the boat and
we can sneak across the pier. If anyone sees us to shoot. No no. Shut up
Willie. You remember that guy I told you about James. I have a crush on
sent in walkers to save us from Lily and Abel. Maybe we could convince him to
do it again if we leave or he didn't put them onto the beach we can blend in
without being seen.
Well hell yeah. Let's find out how much he charges for his services.
What about after we get everyone home. I mean the rage isn't just come attack us again. What then
High quick. Oh killer killer. Oh I got to click finally something.
Oh why.
My thumb is like on the
what's happening.
There has to be. He will stay here. I'll see if they know anything that could
help us
Drop it. I got you bitch. Huh. You're mine now
and then.
How many raiders are there and how many of you are there.
How many of.
Shut up. I'm not fucking around. Answer the clear. Eight. There's eight.
You lied to me one more time and your throat is gonna get.
Oh hey Minnie. Oh she's one of the
past captives. Ya
I heard they burned half your school down Ruby. Mitch. Brody.
Saw. Them. For holes in rubber
Duct taped him up the last time I saw but that was a while ago. Spooks are fine.
The girl who took over after Harlan died. That everyone would want to
lean on their own. I didn't ask to be put in charge. It just sort of happened.
April security could top Marilyn into handing everyone over like he really did.
He ruined the whole plan. Oh my gosh what has happened. Marlin
traded through itself like it was nothing. Good point
actually have her meet.
Is. Sophie. She died protecting the Delta.
Hero
A hero. Shit. Shit. Okay
everyone. Get down.
Okay we're getting out. Finish up and head back. I want to be in before dark.
Sorry I was just staring at my backs. Yes ma'am.
Our boat leaves for the delta in two days. Then it'll be a couple of weeks
before we can come back for the rest of you.
When we do don't fight the only way we have a save your people is to let us
take them. I'm serious. Don't fight this.
The last time where people attacked us you lost two men. You'll lose more if you
come back.
Will she though will she vowed.
Cool.
Look at her go
are you OK.
It doesn't change anything. We still have to get onto that boat.
All right let's get to it guys. Come on. All right enough talk about feelings.
He should head home. Start getting things ready. Get everyone caught up on the
plan. That's right. When except 10.
I warned you all both of you damn aging we'll go find James
Brady has no chill
How old is AJ like 3.
He's absolutely crazy. How could this just do that.
Okay A.J. I'm sorry but like you need to call him.
How many walkers do you think James will help us get. Fifteen one
hundred thousand
Adults. Gunshot wound. It feels like someone
pinched me from inside
And sound that better. Just a second.
Clint
I keep thinking when Billy said all this stuff about tin before I got
so mad. Yes. He was being mean and tin wasn't even there to defend himself.
That's going I heard him. I know I shouldn't but I just can't stop thinking about it.
You're a big old poopy head. Punch his head. You're a big old fuck you won't keep breathing kicking rocks.
I don't like this feeling.
Well you get angry. I just let the anger pass.
I know it's hard A.J. But thoughts like that go away. You just have to give it
time. Weightings hard just thinking too much.
Don't do your head might explode. I think. I think I'm mad at into
Running at a cover when Lily attacked the school was really stupid but he just
doesn't know stuff like we do. And then Willie started yelling at him instead
of helping him learn wasn't the other kids know all the stuff we know. When
there's a plan. You have to follow it. And when you yell at someone it just
makes them not listen. OK well teach them. Saw them. They're smart. Someone
just has to show them what to do. Yeah I want to know how to be safe.
We can show them how to be smart like us. It's weird that people care about us.
It is Erickson's boarding school for troubled youth troubled year
troubled like Bear. Yeah like these are the bad things. Why yes ok
sometimes they do them because bad things happen to them.
I knew a doctor once back when you were just a baby. He called it trauma. You
have some to you know the thing where people can't walk up behind you.
I don't like my trauma. I want to get it off of me. How do I get rid.
I don't even like the way the words five as some are sold consecutively and then
it should do the trick. I'm Fuck sorry. It's just not a way to get rid of it.
You'll get help because they suck. I still like them
As anything happened to AJ that makes everything so about people coming up
behind the scenes on this but actually I think he's my first real friend.
Hell yeah I thought I was your first real friend. Oh
Yeah. But you don't count. You're old. Oh and no rain. He's my second face Wilfred
Damn Clementine just got savaged by a 3 year old.
You think the guy's near is that it.
Vast Web 2.0. Huh. OK. I am under. The Shah of Iran.
Hello. Hello. Well I didn't know that I am in error on our part.
I don't see James just monsters. Okay. Racist.
James get hurt.
Get her to the readers to this new fortnight dance.
It looked like they had people from your school. Why are you here.
Those people you saw were going to save them. And you're gonna help us for no
reason to do that. We need your help moving some walkers.
I could maybe help but my mask is still in the camp inside my back. I can't pass through a herd without it.
Ok. Let's go get it please. I just would just ask that you don't kill them. The
walkers. If you distract them so ride over and find my mask. Destroy to all of them please I'll try
Ok. Use e to stun them. OK so we're just gonna stun them. Oh my God.
What happened there. All right shift to run. I can't run here. Craig
I just have to survive for some time. I'm dead. Now.
Her niece. Niece.
How long I can keep this up. Did you find your mask. Can't find it. The horses
must. Bear. The horses at random ask. Them. To run.
Thanks for helping out AJ. More like. JJ.
From. The league will draw him away. Get it. Cause he's
Clicking so hard Oh wow. And now there it is. Did it. Yeah. Look
where he's pushing
A name. Get those knees Clementine.
You know I do. Oh hell no.
And now kiss
Pj are you okay. Yeah. No lights
Except mine. I know it would have been easier to kill them. Right. I appreciate
it. Yeah.
No I'm not. I'm glad you're here.
Oh God it's so horrifying
thank you for helping me get this back now
How will walkers save your friends. They're being held captive on a boat not too
far from here. We can't sneak on board without cover. Not without the Raiders
gunning us down. You want to use walkers to hide to sneak on board their ship.
That's insane. It's our only chance.
I have something I want you to see. You can understand what you're asking. Okay.
James does they're just gonna die.
How is he gonna show us something actually interesting and revealing about the
zombies. Maybe that's something that we don't know about. Maybe they actually
have some behavior that is actually where
That would be epic.
A. It's
safe. I like how he makes it so easy. Just throw a
rock and get rid of the zombie further. Refighting them off like
hopelessly for years and then it's gonna throw rock.
Against
Us. Pretty cool
A.j.. Now is not the time to take a shit. Jesus Christ. Did someone just take
our shit. We are flush in their toilet.
Well I was 1 2 years. My people and my former
people. They had a practice
Called they can talk without moving a little bit. Collecting my people.
Okay. We have an army.
This is epic.
They use them as a weapon. I do this. To protect them. I know it sounds
strange. But that's why I brought you here. To see them as I do
As people. Was it nice to if there were people how is it nice people don't like
exactly. But
Something in between. Part of us is still in their
Deep down. Yeah I think so anymore. We turn.
Not dead not alive.
God we hope that's not true. That sounds like hell. To you maybe.
I think it seems
Peaceful. Sigh. So do you really think there's
people inside of monsters. Somewhere. Yes. So what do you think
about it this way. As someone you cared about turned. Not.
Kim's friend. Lee
She shot him before he did.
Oh. She doesn't like to talk about it.
Her sorry. Maybe this wasn't the best way to explain. Didn't mean to bring up
difficult memories. I lived among walkers for years. Still do
anyway. When they're alone. They're harmless.
Innocent. If you want my help
I need you to try and walk with them.
Walk with me. I believe they're just monsters. Okay I'm down. They are
just monsters kidnap people or friends. Claim oh my gosh what just happened.
She'll be safe. I really need to set up my lines. This isn't smart. It's too
dangerous. Yeah. I want to do it. I'm smarter. I'll need you to save me. Okay.
Can you do that. Yes
He'll always protect you. I know you will.
You the sound
It up but don't ever go alone.
I'm not leaving you. I'll be right back.
Check the windows. I will. Don't let fear take over.
I will. I promise. All right AJ. The
mask will disguise your scent but be gentle. And be quiet
Touch the wind chime. You'll see. The hell is this guy on.
This is some hippie made be my Joe buddy. Oh I'm not touched the wind chimes
Okay. This tackle
First person action happening. Hey guys what's up. What did somebody do in their
spare time. Somebody rave. Let's all do the floss fourth night dance in
unison. I think that would be really epic. Imagine how many views on YouTube we
could get. Or maybe we could just do the DAB.
Oh sorry. They're like a total lie. So like pushing each other.
Loss like a bone loss. Like a flower.
Long
Like in the bowels. Come on man dude we're so close to the.
Dude we are so
She looks so funny.
I Don't want to win. Oh my God. You gotta go down. Now married our director.
Oh my God. Darwin
God damn that is not a good look for you Clementine I am sorry. Oh my God what a
good day. To win.
Oh my God. I'm Robert. I'm Robert. Oh my God.
You
Hate your kiddo. That was cute. Gonna have to take a lunch break. Hey we're back. Everybody is gaming time bites. Guy. No.
What are you doing. Do you still think they're just monsters. Yes. Yes I do.
You've seen them at peace.
Yeah. Yeah I do. They're still just monsters. Dangerous things. Jesus to kill
us. That's what I thought you would say. It's what I ever said
to. Once. Okay. What changed. Every killed a welcome before. I.
Have
Many. Have you ever killed a person. Again. I
swear to God to you I will kill a person and that person is you. But that was a
long time ago.
I've killed someone before too. AJ. AJ You have killed someone.
No I'm not afraid to kill again. I'm a murderer
But I try to atone. What's up dude. Well. That's cause you never told
me in videos anymore. You never told me and Rick Harrow HMAS Wagga you're going
to help us save our friends Kojak Why. Can I wear a mask. Can I eat a
mask but I can't.
So many walkers would die. Yeah. Dominic would die and I would be a dad would cost
I'm sorry Clementine. I can't have more blood on my hands.
Giles Well they don't have a bright one with the different eyes. What was his name. His name. What do you. How about the woman in the back. Hear the wind chimes What's her name.
I don't know. Assem. Omar
Violent. Those are the names of my friends the ones who were stolen by the
Raiders. I'll never forget that
Always a show by J Edgar. George asking. Why he's
such a pussy. I may be stubborn but I'm not heartless.
Those. Raiders are cruel. Yeah. We convinced him we're a.
Culprit AP. And even if your friends think like you
Don't want to serve. Hey YouTube do want to see my secret I have extra nipple.
It takes a look at the desk and through the forest to the Sure. There's all your dad had my extra leg.
I don't.
I don't care. Are you ready. Don't do this. Here. Looks like your
testicle parents a. Charge true J.J Dompig
such a pushing 40 I cash to call.
Go fight for my chair why. Ya
Okay it's it's Chamberlain time.
Gaming with anger and feelings get back before it's too I don't have to press
any buttons anyway so it's not like it makes a difference also now
drink in G fuel
Or you can't. Day
I've never minded I wish I can I have to. I mean he's tough. Not like
you though he didn't kill monsters but now he's not scared of them either.
He's cool Hey Clem.
Willie told me the plan. How things go with that guy James. He agreed to help
us. If somebody told me we were gonna sneak onto a boat and a herd of walkers
had called them crazy. What are you doing with those. Yeah. Good question.
I wanted to throw one last hootenanny before the hootenanny I swear.
Huh. It sounds like a swear. Yeah.
What's that. Who. Was a hootenanny. What the fuck is that. Who do namely sing and party.
I wanna get out of here. Oh my God. Right turn now from Chicago.
I'll need something new if their spirits right about now. This could be her last
chance. Mm hmm. I wouldn't make some tea for everyone. Could I borrow your
little heater thing. What can I do. We need to pretty up the old music room.
Could you make us something colorful to hang up. Okay.
I'll be an artist. All right.
I get this. What is this.
What do you call it to make the deck the deck or decoration
decoration for the party. Okay. Okay. I'll get the heater
Oh look I get to do stuff.
Okay so plays the collectibles before leaving. Don't mess it up Bo. Okay so coffee.
Yeah. Just that welfare riot in my pocket. Okay. Shop quite a diet in the game
page not core. The developer worked very hard on that. Oh I'm foreign. Help me.
I'm actually your dish iron ore my boy.
Hey you're getting better at this. Soon you'll be as good an artist as ten.
Yeah. No no he's really good. Oh. Something wrong. I was just thinking about stuff while I was drawing
There are three kinds of lies. Oh yeah
they're alive people lives.
We add those. Then there's monsters I usually look like dirty water other
times monsters eyes aren't even white and then they're alive people eyes. Why
did you kill him like you did to Abel. Jesus. His eyes look like you blew a
candle out. He was a bad guy. More shouldn't feel like this. I
hated him too. I think there's something wrong with me. You know what A.J.
everything you're feeling. You're a good person.
It makes you a good person. Am I good
I want to be better clean let people know I'm good. Just by my face. You're the best. Okay. I'm getting real smart now.
Think so. Is that right.
Yes because I'm always thinking all the time Hey what are you thinking about right now. You getting big turning into a monster.
Oh thanks yeah. The older I get the more I see it.
I don't know why what happened.
Bradford's see anyone can eat you dead matter if you're inside or outside of how
careful you are. Well first it would suck like big time
And then I'd have to numb you.
Nom Nom AJ foreshadowing everyone is gonna have better what we talked about
what you're supposed to do if it happens.
Listen to me if I get bit you'll run away as fast.
No no I'm not going to do that. AJ You price don't care.
I'm not leaving you.
If you get bit I don't want you to bite me too gay.
Why haven't you dropped me Maggie. Please don't be mad. I
can't live with you not with me. I know we've talked about it so much
but to make me OK.
That's how you want it. When I turned into a monster I will bite you. Really.
Yeah. Like so hard. Be serious Clem
You can't break promises A.J. No.
Except people do all the time in this video game.
Jesus Christ James said guess not that we could be around
much like on the inside if you got bit bit me.
Maybe we'd still be together. It would just be a different together.
You might even be OK.
You think so. Let's say James might be right. That monsters have part of the
person they were still inside them. The thing is no one can prove that.
And if we can't prove it we're not going to risk our lives over it.
Can I go patrol for a bit before the party. Sure. Go ahead. Be careful.
I don't think he's gay. She'd have a gun. I'm sorry I should have. I'm going on patrol.
So patrolling the thing I'm patrolling the thing
Oh my God.
I was wondering. Well I can't help but thinking what what do you want.
You shot that Raider who grabbed me. But you saw them take violent too. Which
means you could have saved Violet and not me.
Why would you pick me.
I mean I wouldn't have picked me. Hell I don't know anyone who would've picked me.
I honestly didn't have time to think didn't really have time to think I just
made a split second decision.
What do you want me to say. I love you and I want to be with you because I don't.
I know I'm always teasing her trying to get her to do that one eye roll she
does. You know the one where it's like you're such a dumb ass she has to do a
full body eye roll.
Yeah I do it because when I actually do manage to make her
laugh it's worth it.
If I needed her she'd be their meat cleaver in hand ready to chop someone in half if it meant protecting me.
Hey we're going to get them back.
Lewis Yeah damn right we will pay Gran Oh
no I messed it up I wasn't ready my hand was in my oh head guy.
She's going to get it in their face. Oh I got it. God.
Wow. Where did you find a beach ball. It was in some garbage behind one of the
girls. I had to blow it up and that was pretty gross. But look it works.
Start heading back to the admin building school right.
Yeah. Yeah.
Toss it in his face. Think fast.
Again.
I love you. I love you back kiddo.
Okay. We better get ready to go.
Sounds like such a nice moment. Ok.
Did you guys do the thing when you were kids your shitty drawings he would sell
them to your parents hair.
We still need to figure out lighting means remember what a dick move. That was
something to write on that banner.
If we're going to die we should have some fun first.
You put prices on them and stuff like that. Me and my sister were there.
God no I want to actually attend this thing. Oh I get to choose. Candle color.
Oh yeah. Yeah. Already without some kind of mood I was sure with Prozac. Red
Purple or green. I can't green. I can't do it.
I'm just gonna have to make triple dot and then get some facial moonlight so
something to complement that maybe I should leave it to me. Then don't be
surprised if it's green or green. That is happen. Check this
out. When you turn that crank there it plays me pulled out the old headmaster's
gramophone so I could play some records def machos election by I should do.
Wouldn't happen to have any good jazz records would you. Hell yeah. I wish to
pick country teacher it was a big fan. Pretty cool guy up until he ditched us
all. Let's jazz like it'll make sense when you hear it.
Do you like jazz A.J. huh.
Are we using the banner for some kind of party theme. Not exactly. It's meant to
be more motivational.
I keep it short though it's not as much room as you think A.J. or edgy pick with
something. Really. I have an idea.
It'll be us telling people to put stuff on sciences and really my strong saying
OK we'll have to break out his paintbrush and write it out.
This place is gonna look great.
I think with the green it's really going to pop. But that's just my opinion.
Dude is that a crank in the middle of the world asking for you. He's up in
Marlon's office setting out a surprise for the party but he wanted to show it to you first.
You crank out wall
he can check it out. I found a bunch of books on ships.
Ok here's some awesome stuff about fires at sea and explosions and stuff. The
key is the boiler. WAIT WHAT ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT. YOU MAKE THE BOILER idea
about how to stop those assholes coming back to the school after we rescued the
others from hurting anyone else ever again.
We're going to blow up the boat.
I like this guy. Sure this guy is on my mind. I know this feels right. You know
for Mitch.
Uh is it me or is there a bit of a bomb obsession at this school.
What was that you told me as well for good reason. The tricky bit is timing
the explosion so that it happens after you get off the boat.
Oh yeah trying to blow out the boat.
This'll work will be okay. Now I'm into it. Everybody get ready.
Go
Clean. I'm sorry for before. But how he treated 10. All right. Colby
get so angry. I know it's not his fault.
I apologize. Just because he had a good idea for once in your life.
Oh yeah. Write it down.
Oh. That is ugly.
I'm flashing
Wow this looks great Ruby done it without you.
But just wait to see what else I've got planned. Go ahead and mingle. I'll let
you know when it's time. I guess I'll mingle.
I see you two are working together. Yeah. Willie asked me to help with his special project. That's nice. Is it ready. Good did go. Clem
It'll work. Let's blow out the frickin bomb. It's gonna be just like I was
thinking maybe we should name it
Something cool. Yeah. I mean I think it deserves a name. Yeah we absolutely have
to name it. I thought you make fun of me but. Hell yeah. His name is fucker
Willie Junior. Ruby's revenge. Ruby's revenge Hoskin. Ruby
Here. Hell yeah. Ruby's revenge.
Oh no wait. Damn right. I don't like that actually. Never mind.
Well it's better than my idea which I'm not gonna say out loud some
Ok. Clementine. These here are official Erickson's psych evaluations and
probationary reports. O okay. Oh good. Well
these explain why all of us got sent to this school in the first place.
And how we got stuck here for as long as we did.
So what's the game. I figured if we're all going on this crazy mission together
not as we'll know who we really are. So I'll read some of what the DA are they
not found this before it is going to finally have to guess which one of us fits
the bill. I'll make sure someone you've actually met. This will be the first
one. Wow. Otherwise a remarkable student blank
continues to be plagued by fits of anger uncontrollable cursing and repeated
physical altercations at the senior faculty.
And That's all of you.
I don't know Marlon but not to speak ill of the dead but that sounds exactly
like Marlon.
Oh my God Marlon. Are you there. Yes it does. But no it. Wasn't him.
That's Ruby's file. Holy shit was Ruby guilty as charged.
Our sweet Ruby here was kind of a nightmare when she first showed up who she
once she's the home ec teacher around the yard with a barbecue fork this big.
No way.
Don't worry I was a long time ago.
I mean I can totally see it the first time I met Ruby. She was all that little motherfucker. Said I was sorry. You guys went away I got sent here
No food no chronic masturbation.
Kay guys gonna end that
episode there. Hope you guys enjoyed watching smash like if you enjoyed.
And also remember to sub scribe. Okay fine.
Willy. I speak for all of us when I say nobody has ever. Ever wanted to know that. Was Me.
Have we ever shake this hand. Have we ever touched him
Anyway. Maybe we should change up the music. Like all kinds of different music.
I think. There's a lot of them.
Sure. Country roads just country on. Hey take me home
To the freight.
I'll be right with you.
It's pretty nice.
I didn't realize how many of us we lost. I remember that Justin guy. And the
risks Jasper that one girl with colored braces and Joey
Maddie Lamar
She had the braces. Alex to me Trey Stephanie.
Yeah. This seemed like a bad many of us died. Four.
Jesus
Well you know you live some you lose some. You know what you can do cry about it.
Whose is it violets.
Well the point of the game was that you weren't gay. All right. I. I could tell you guys my story. Instead what got me sent here.
I mean chronic masturbation if you want.
It's not great.
I was saying Jeez tell me so
my family was stupid rich parents gave me everything I wanted when I wanted it.
Except for one thing. Singing lessons.
I begged my dad told him I wanted to be a real musician but all he said was you
get to be happy or you get to be rich. Can't be both.
I know now that he was just trying to teach me a dumb dad lesson but I hated him
for that. I was a dad lesson so I decided I'd teach him a lesson.
I thought I'll break up my parents marriage. That hurt real bad right. OK.
I broke into my dad's credit card accounts and made all these purchases in his name.
Did this for over a year. This is how rich we were.
He never noticed he was spending a fortune on a mistress that I'd made up for
him. Oh. But I made sure my mom did. Oh send her all the receipts for the
hotel rooms the jewelry all of it. Damn he's slick.
They had a fight all night long. He denied it. She wouldn't have it. I sat in
the corner and cried to help it feel more real.
When their divorce was final I told them the truth.
Oh I said you get to be happy or you get to be rich. You don't get to be both.
Well my. You know
Those two would have been happily married forever. But then I had to go be a vindictive kid.
I mean.
Oh my God I came here the week after.
I mean at least you don't have chronic masturbation as your option.
That's OK. So that's pretty fucked up.
I'm in complete and total agreement. They said we were bad people Glenn
they went wrong. Still went wrong. None of us deserve to be ditched out here in
the middle of the forest by the people that we're supposed to make us better.
Sorry. This is supposed to be fun. Yeah I guess I'm not really a game person.
What kind of person are you violent beat yourself up. You said it yourself. Clem
needs to know who she is leading into battle.
Hey I've got an idea. You can call in many would sing it. Don't be
afraid when all of it you get scared.
Of course I remember. Yeah. I helped compose it with her. Could you maybe
play it for us.
If I was here she could sing the word but yeah yeah I'd love to. 10
This is for you many actually like the green.
I'll ask someone that doesn't look good in green I'm sorry but damn
I should have picked something else.
Why.
I was thinking too already in or AJ.
Now let's blow out about who's with me. Blow out the boat.
Blow up the boat blow up the boat. Come on everybody let's blow out the boat.
Blow up the boat. Tragic tragic tragic. Yeah.
Oh no. The feels. Don't do me like this.
Lee. Hey sweet pea
My God. She was so precious
To him. He looks good. Damn right. They always put the tray.
I'm not sure. Maybe because this is where it all started.
Ah you taught me to shoot and to cut my hair. To be ready for what was coming.
You were a quick study. So what's on your mind this time.
Worriedly. I've got a lot of people depending on me and I don't know if what I'm doing is right.
Oh I know that feeling. You know I was making it all up as it went along right.
I couldn't let on of course
I don't think you were fooling anyone.
Don't feel bad. Monsters took over the world. You got stuck taking care of an
eight year old girl. What were you supposed to do
I guess. A little too little huh.
You want to tell me about what you're up against. I'm with a new group now. Can
I've been in so many
And they always fall apart. I really like this one. It's. Different.
It almost feels like home.
That's a good thing. Typing alone out there.
But we're in trouble. Some bad people captured my friends and getting them back
might get the rest of us killed.
Whatever trouble you have
You get out of it. You get your friends out of it you don't know that
I know you're a survivor. Clementine I know was gonna fix it.
I really believe that you're right.
I just needed to hear you say. I'm going to get my friends out of this.
Every one of them. Alive.
That's right. Imagine how five it will feel when she finds out you came to
rescue her. You'll have given our hope again.
Oh sweet pea. You know you always get like this before something big remember
how scared you were before you charged into that massive McCarroll brand. You survived that didn't you.
That was different. I was alone
I know. It's harder when you have something to lose. But haven't people you care about. That's a good thing. Fighting beside you because of you.
Come see me again when you've gotten them out okay. Out safe.
And hopefully we can talk about happier things. I
miss you so much I wish you were you here.
I miss you too. Clementine. Will have to make do with pretending.
All. Thank you Lee talking to you
always makes me feel a little bit better
Jumps up the train task ask how's the boy he's cuddly
you'd like him. You teach him to shoot.
Yeah I did and it was terrible idea. You have no idea. Yeah exactly.
Yeah I guess we all got pretty hard since I left a kid growing up in it.
He'd be hard to. You're in my shoes now raising a kid
think you got a handle on it all right.
Yeah. I can't be I want to give him a childhood but knowing what it takes to survive now is amazingly time to be strong and brave and capable
He'd be so proud.
You made more than I already am.
Hall
But it's not real.
Wow
Just look at you. Just look at you.
I told you to keep this short. You don't know how hard it is to find scissors these days.
You've got people that need you.
Goodbye Lee.
Damn. Clint wake up.
It's time to go.
We've got a long walk I can a little
flap of the cap is like falling up. I just notice that.
Finally a real moment. Very nice. So.
This kind of moment you mess
With these games. That's what makes them worthwhile in my opinion.
Damn that was unnecessary. You can just throw a rock you and the waste. Ah ah ah.
Oh my gosh I'm dying.
She's gonna go disguise. I guess we're really
doing this only the team blending in with the Walkers need to cover themselves.
Now we just need your walker friend here.
Good Lord. Yeah. Hello.
As you may imagine a very nice to meet you guys. This is James.
He's my friend now. You don't have any friends aging. He's so
cool. All right don't masturbate on him like that. Oh my
Clementine Cartwright on. That's not a good. Quiet. Someone might hear you loud is bad.
Thanks. Aging out loud. Yeah absolute brainless.
Sorry I'll be quiet.
Oh and sorry a trade issue that one time your mask looks so real
functional and fashionable.
I'll take two. Funny huh.
Is this the guy that Clinton said she'd marry.
Yeah. Can I speak to you alone for a moment. Good idea hold tight.
Hey ya. Come here buddy. I got you something.
The Walkers. They'll be here in a little while. You can join them as they pass
through the trees. The noise from the boat will drive them toward the water and
we can get on board and save our friends.
Your friends are different. Open minded accepting.
Maybe one day you'll be the same.
Yeah that sound is disgusting mess and Clementine.
I need to talk to you about AJ. He put it in front of my yard the
whisperers are my family. From a young age. That time I witnessed
a lot of death suffering eventually I became the cause of it.
Witness was considered a poison and I believed in that fiercely
so much so that when another boy expressed sympathy for our enemy before an
attack. Struck
And consider who he was what he felt. Honestly I don't even remember his name.
After he died I kept hearing his words in my head. Those people were like us
just on a different path. I stopped killing. After that. I changed. When
else Ted. When 80 told me he killed someone. It reminded me of.
Myself. He said it was wrong. It sounded like he was just repeating what he'd
been told. Taking life like that from a young age. It breaks something inside you. That just
Afraid of aging kills again. You won't be able to go back. To Chung that you
like commercial. Boy he was able to fix it. I've seen it happen too many times.
I'm not going let AJ become a killer. I want it to change not like that. I hope
you can keep that promise
Class. Soon there will be enough of them to provide us cover. Blow up the boat
I'll lead you through the hurt until you reach the boat blow up the boat's
psycho. After that it's up to you.
This is blogged about. Let's blow up the boat guys. Like what do you guys want to do. Take care of A.J.
Okay. He's ready to go. A.J. give me the gun.
The Walkers are getting close. Ruby you're in charge of the horses. Ted
take care of the supplies and I'm in charge of the bomb.
Find the boiler. There'll be a door on the bottom with ash and stuff.
Put it in there.
See you all on the other side.
Ok not on the zombie side I hope.
That would be really bad all right. What do you want
Luis told me about Minnie
That Sophie died and Minnie is one of them. Just
if you see you're out there. Tell her. Tell her I forgive her. Please. I tell her myself.
Sharon I just want it to be OK. Yeah. All right. Should I wait. Sure. If we see
her I'll let her know.
Thanks bye.
I'm gonna talk to everyone about their feelings before we go in got their feelings.
Clementine. Before we go there isn't it. Before we go and do this thing that we
get to do I just first need to.
Lives are depending on us depending on me you're depending on me too.
What if something happens to you. Clem. What if what if I can't
I don't know. I can't carry that the rest of my life. You just have to try. You
have to try Luis no matter what you think about yourself. Get lost if you don't
go. They all are. You can't fall apart right now. No not now.
I wish I could help it. Okay I'll
try. Cool. What if I just get his car too. All it would take is one little
screw up and I screw up all the time. All right. Come on Lewis. Get it together
I need you to slap me. Help pull me out of this. Right here.
Come on. Just give him my voice.
You'll be OK. I Like that a lot more.
It's ready.
Okay. Oh we're not doing what I think we are. That depends. What do you
think we're doing. Oh God. We are. It'll help us blend in with the Walkers.
Use guts. Okay so it takes guts and me rub it on their clothes. We could have changed clothes before so we don't waste our outfits.
But they're now looks so gross here.
That's a nice jacket. Do you like it so Nauru.
You're not open up your mouth.
There you know Walker blood is one of the hardest times to get out.
You owe me some new clothes we gonna do it.
We're doing it. Here we frickin go charge attack.
Country roads take me home Me too to pay I blow. Blow up boats. And. Save the kids
Take me home. Boo boo boo. Okay. All right.
Hi. Oh. That was Jerry.
Use them as shields. All right. Okay.
It's. Hug time.
Grab. It at that. Ski
Mary Beth. Oh shoot. Did he just shot my new friend.
All right. Do you want to be my friend. Hug time.
God. Damn it.
All right looks we it.
I. Feel like I'm doing this wrong.
Get rid of me. Fucking Walker. On. Willie
Supplies. It's really like it. Someone get over there and see what's going on
What in the world. Now's our chance.
Oh my God.
We can't risk leaving cover. We'll have to call on the side of the dog.
This is a slam out anyway. Like what's the zombie move
really necessary. I guess so.
Well you know you lived some you lose some. Let's just get up here. Oh no that's
bad. Okay. Now let's go gross. Shooter in the pin that's.
Follow me
This way. I don't know if it's me that's lagging or if it's do there's some is in the water.
This is like Pirates of Caribbean. That episode and they. Like oh we're going to walk
And then they walk. It's really cool. I don't know if you have seen that. But
it's really cool.
Well I'm glad I have this amazing piece. Oh hey hey hey. There's sharks
That freak is your problem. I'm not a wind chime OK
It's so like it. What happened.
Ok. I'm fine. I'm gonna
restart. I need to wait for a check point. What do I do.
This is super annoying. Let me see if I can restart my recording. Three two one.
Ok. Oh good
Ok.
Here we go. Game three. This is to prove once and for all.
I'm. Gay. No.
Jesus Christ a laggard in legs at the same spots too so it must be the game.
Ready AJ. P.S. master race is more like P.T..
Crap. Beast of state
All right. And. Call.
Right in there. Bananas. All this shit is lag days.
I can't play like this. Am. I going to use the arrow away.
Hi. I need to do something. This is crazy.
Okay. As. Soon as we go in here I'm going to restart. Again. That's the same.
Perfect.
Ever since I was a kid. And in an jaw line.
Man. I remember. Oh they got more hay and stuff.
Dude we're getting close to the boiler and place the bomb. We'll get her friends
out. He said there were eight Raiders. We didn't see that many outside.
All right. And this has been going on for long enough and I haven't said
anything but they are stealing the plot from beyond two souls. OK they do the
exact same thing. They go on the boat and then they blow up the boat. Am I just
going to pretend that they're not played you. Oh shit. Hey.
Conveniently placed
As cover. Very nice. Did none of us have guns. Not a single gun. I'm gonna go in here chicken in. You do that as well when he came under a door.
Yeah.
Let's blow it up son.
OK. I. Feel like God right there
It's banana man. You ever heard of the banana man. Eating bananas.
Eyes
This guy likes it bananas.
Uh knock out the chicken. I think we'll go for a knockout and then we'll kick
it's gotten. Them
But shoot them in the face. That was pretty bad ass. Not gonna lie
We're gonna blow at the boat so he's gonna die anyway unless someone drags him out. Looks like That's where we need to plant the bomb. There's too much stuff. Maybe there's another way.
Sure. Yeah. Wasting ammo.
All right. So. What's the planning. Wait here.
Shoot him. And
He's going to die anyway. I'm sorry but let's get I killed myself. No. Bye
Bye.
Pi.
Time to live up to your name. Ruby's revenge. Love and support you once they start up this boat. You won't have much time before it explodes.
Phone Hello. Not sure. An hour 30 minutes. I guess we'd better move
It's me. It's my sister. I don't know what she wants. I'm sorry honey but I'll
talk to you later.
Um okay. Sorry I missed what was happening because it. Uh reasons my mother and
I go upstairs. Okay. Sure.
I can't believe I just killed Katie pie focus.
I have a little brother. He's a short scarred face. See he's not out there easy.
Look we've discussed this. Your family is Delta now. There ain't no room for
anyone else. Yes ma'am.
There's no way we can get in there without her seeing us
Shoot her in the face. Put her in the place.
Get out. Not without our people. I swear to
God. You got caught up in this. Just just tell me that he's
safe. Me that he told me to tell you he forgives you.
I'll help you get everyone out. Then you take my brother
And run get him back to where it's safe. You can come with us.
Come on.
We have to hurry.
Clementine fuck. Guy. Are you OK. What's up homies.
Yeah I'm all right. We're all right. Get Violet first. She needs to know you're here.
This guy killed Violet face. She needs to know we're here. You don't have a lot
of time before Doreen comes back. Blow up the boat.
Blow up the boat. Lewis give me a hand. Yeah sure. Violet shocked.
I mean it. So go find it. Like.
Many.
Get it yourself. Oh shit do. Oh shit. Oh
You kill her. AJ. Kill her. Thanks for that. Violent things
a lot violent. The boat is gonna blow up violent.
Hey it's me. Thanks for coming back to me. Sorry I can hear you.
And uh
Why.
Are you okay.
Talk to me.
We're here to take you home. I looked for you when they grabbed me. I saw you
let them take me. I'm just supposed to forget that because you're here now.
Some fucking friend you are fools wouldn't have stood a chance against these
guys. I knew you could fight back.
Yeah sure. What's wrong with you right. Come on. Yeah. Get the hell out of here.
No Clem
I'm done. This whole situation is so fucked.
Police here have many. You mean the many that betrayed us. Don't act like you
know her. She tried to escape her and Sophie. They said if
I fight back they'd kill many or one of you. All you've done is get us hurt or
killed if you fuck this up worse.
I'll stop you myself and don't think I won't. I'm using her
again or anyone else.
Can't give up now. If they take us back to their community. We'll all die. So
what your plan is to speed up the process. Whatever you do leave me out of it
Okay.
Escape. All right. That's like they have scratch in here that long.
Well we physically can't because it looks like there's a gap here.
Boat is about to blow my hand through no. That would have changed everything.
Are you all got caught. Jesus. Christ. Are you all right. I'm fine.
Where's A.J.. Yes I am all right. Thank you for asking.
It's vile right. She's saying she won't help us with the shit.
Being a bit of a sacrifice to be honest.
We're not moving yet. So at least we've got some time. I guess
What.
Violet you must help me. Please please. I love Violet Colby.
Yeah. Call me Violet.
Call me a fag.
Yeah.
How you holding up. Well she scares the shit out of me clamp
extra earlier. Nice talk. Fuck. I don't think I've ever been that
afraid. She's not messing around. Yeah come soon. Just hang in there. Yeah.
You dated Schumer A.J.. Yeah I'm all right. I'm looking for a way out. Yeah.
I like how he has his little window. Very well made. Maybe that's something we
can work with. Perhaps if we like spit on them and it's acid. So it looks.
Are you all right.
Me. Yeah I'm fine. Just trying to figure out the best way to survive an explosion.
All right. Come on guys. If we work together we can solve anything. Violet.
This is where you'd be disgusting.
Maybe we can use the pill of acid
All right. Anywhere. From
This note there. We haven't talked to a moderate heart. Just get out are you.
Yeah. Well thank you.
Let's just get a..
What can I say except your own ma
think that GQ is kicking in.
Oh latch that freaking
latch bro I might be able to chip away at this.
If I had a tour dad must have taken away my knife.
But want your coffee maker. You have your coffee maker in your back pocket.
You still have your knife. Yeah. They didn't find it. Only the big one. Good.
I need you to slide it over to me.
Nice
Or murder. Go
Don't tell me. Uh huh uh.
Uh uh uh uh uh.
Bye bye add that BAP BAP BAP out I might I buy that.
Come on cut my shave with some pieces.
Let's get this fucking door. Come on come on.
Just open.
Really. Whatever you're doing. Don't. Time's
up. I was you.
It ain't worth it. Stabbed in the back. She awake.
Yes ma'am. Slide the shiv away. Oh
I'm not going to forget. Oh
Hey Eric I get it. Yo
where's Abel.
He's dead. We killed him. We put a knife in his head.
She's a little monster. We showed him mercy.
He was terrified of turning so we stopped him from having to. We gave him what
he wanted. I am sure you did back up.
Minerva. Open the door. Yes ma'am.
Normally the trouble you caused.
I'd shoot you and toss you overboard
but I'm genuinely impressed.
First you organized these idiot kids into a fighting force and killed two of my
most experienced soldiers.
Then you sneak onto my boat under the cover of a herd I bring a prize like you
back to the Delta. It might make this whole cluster fuck of a mission worth it.
Someone like you so young with so much potential.
Look if I'm the one you want. Let the others go. This isn't a negotiation. This
is me telling you how things are going to be.
You know my father Larry was a military man. And Larry that's not even a real man.
All kinds of rules. The thing that bugged him most was waste. If I ever left a
light on after leaving a room he'd flip. No matter how many times he ranted
about the cost of electricity I could never remember to hit that switch.
It sounds like you were a dumbass kid.
So one day he let our power get cut.
He liked illustrations to show that actions have consequences.
Jesus Christ he looks terrifying Omar hairdryer. No more ice cream sandwiches.
Well I guess asshole runs in the family. Is that ice cream sandwiches.
Is that the consequences. I never left the lights on again. My father had his
faults but he showed me the effectiveness of teaching by example. Oh is that what this is a lesson.
I want to tell you a story. Let's call it the parable of the twins
two girls were taken from their home and brought to a new place to live.
They had to leave their friends and family behind and that was hard at first.
They said a lot of tears but the new place was a good place.
The people there grew corn and raised pigs. And the twins eat well for the first time in years.
They had hot showers clean clothes beds. They were given guns and trained to use them.
The people there were kind to these girls all that was asked in return was that
they helped defend the group.
You see this place had a lot of enemies killers and thieves who wanted what they
had. They needed help fighting or they lose everything they built their crawl.
Oh my God how generous even their lives putting guns and families will be
interesting in the fight. How generous they were just doing what they needed to
survive. One of the girls saw that this was a place worth fighting for and
her tears dried
But the other twin she could never forget her old home.
She rejected every gift every opportunity stirred up trouble every chance she got.
She convinced her sister to help her steal a raft and leave on the river.
Of course they didn't get far. What happened then Minerva
I killed her. She really. What the fuck is that true. Your own sister.
Why would you do that. She was twisting my head with her
lies. And. I made a mistake. I needed to
show my loyalty to the place I call home.
Like it or not you're one of my people now Clem. The question is which twin are you going to be the loyal one or the dead one.
You. You watched her. You people are fucking still bring her back away from the door.
I'll kill you honestly. All right Lily you made your point.
I'll do what you want. Don't say that Glenn. Look what they did so many.
Just don't hurt anyone else. Good. I'm surprised to hear you bend so easily.
But as I said before
This isn't a negotiation.
Pull the Matthew one out of the cell. It's killing time.
He clearly didn't get the moral of the story. We'll have to help them
understand. Stop. Don't hurt Luis or I'll hurt you.
Oh she. Eggs. You better cool it or you won't get yourself fuck
Easy. Stay still. Please. Come.
Don't A.J. more than it has to. Hey Jay.
That's enough. I said that's enough.
You deserve to die.
You think you can kill me.
I know I can. We'll tell you in the river. I will put a knife right to the side
of your head. They talk for a little guy. I know I can do it.
I killed more. He wasn't. He says his eyes are
Oh my God. AIDS is a bad ass day.
Oh my time. He is the smartest person on the planet with Marlin.
Oh God. She's going to take him. She can turn him around.
I bet you'd make a great soldier. Leave him alone. This is between us
clams seems to care a lot about you.
Come on let's go have a chat. They do a good job on her character. It looks like
You really fits a villain. No no please. A.J. keep an eye on her
Minerva. A movie. I want to be far away from that. I'll start up the boy.
Uh uh you might want it. Don't you dare look at me like that.
It's the only way we survive. Are you serious right now. After everything that
she's done you've just been a helper.
Minerva
How can Minerva have the nerve. What the fuck
You just decided. You don't work for these people I see. Don't get me don't
understand. I'll kill you. Thank you.
Yeah. Violet you being such a fucking spoiled little piece of shit. Honestly.
No buzzing God. You just got seeing it out of nowhere. Yeah.
Behind the plan. How
would you get. All right so I'm pressing q like
very fast. To
Stop. Shoot her. She's gone.
Down the block Oh. No no
Way. It's not
I. Kill. Kill them all stab her in the back. No. Stab her in the knee. I'm sorry. There was a Miss click. It's OK.
It happens.
We have to go. Now we planted a bomb on the boat. Thank
you. There's a bomb maker is dead. You just fucking go.
We have to get the hell out of here now. Go. I need to find Agent. I can. Be
fine. Better see you on land. You will
Could you get in got your game. Good game. Such a game of chicken.
Don't you dare touch him. Hit the boiling on.
No. That's really bad. What's the point. It gets hot enough the whole world folk are just going to go shopping.
Campbell I've known Clementine since before this all started. So
you'll come around to once you see what we have to offer plenty of food
comfortable beds for you and your loving share will. Once you see what we have to offer.
Thank you. She was comfortable saying she really can open you to share a room stuff at once.
I know they can Tennessee.
Did you get lost ma'am. He wasn't alone.
I got some mouth to show this way.
Found Miss hurt
Oh no. They got the ham some weirdo
Must have thought you were clever leading those walkers here. My. Clients had.
Nothing to say. You don't fucking scary
his dad so force your ways onto others cause you're afraid
because you're weak. I give my people a cloth to fight for. The thing about
people like him. A.J. is that they're too broken to fit into a community. They
won't buy for anyone but themselves.
That's not true. He fought for us and he has really big eyebrows.
Shoot him. Shoot him Don't hurt him shoot him just. Stop hurting people
Please. Hey Jay. I'm liking AJ more and
more. All right give me my friend shoot her down the gun. Let them go.
All of us should shoot her. And then you shoot her and then you're good to go.
Fine.
Go ahead. Do it. Save your friend.
That's what you came here to do with the. Oh God.
Oh no. Me too A.J. AJ grab the gun A.J.. A.J. wake up
A.J.. Looks like a soldier A.J. don't.
A.j. would be the best Walker in the game.
Get the gun. God.
Oh
Yeah. Oh God you're so ugly.
You're our
Fighter shift. He attacked. Attack. Now shoot her. Shoot
her. Look. Look look look look look.
I love
You. All right it's so fucking
Agent Agent to me.
Why is it not working than the attacks on.
That's a lot of blood. Matt
A.j. my man. It's A.J..
Oh yes. Hi. I woke give up. Kim
I'll get everyone leave my pro and I will leave. We won't bother you anymore.
Hey her. She's not a threat. Where's the gun. You walk down.
To.
Don't. You. Fucking Mary Jane.
Shoot her in the knees music. Can't
Break her for anyone else. Lower the gun.
I know it's lame but they already warned about it and I don't want him to turn
into an asshole. Even though I desperately want her to shoot him are the
opposite of what I said.
But if it's the wrong choice I'm going back because I'm annoyed about what
is this guy serious.
Did he just turn his back against a woman that has a knife.
This is what happens when you're cut out in a video game. A.J.
She's not a threat. How the guy to walk down. To
She's not a threat. She's not a threat.
The gun can never hurt anyone else doing A.J..
No
No.
Yeah. Yeah. Yes. A date a day.
Whoo hoo hoo.
Really. We couldn't find the other what did you do.
What you see walking dead Pepsi. Oh that'll be the boiler.
Suit the bomb
Ok. What's going to happen next. That was it. OK.
That was it. What's up Bro's.
How's it going. Seven present presented play a force able to turn into a walker.
So very few at three. Wow. Really tough choices this time
around. You and ninety three percent of players respect that James and killed
the Walkers twelve present of players named the bomb brew is
revenge.
Yeah. It was a dumb name.
Honestly 80 percent of players allowed A.J. to attack Dorian stopping her from cutting.
Okay all right. The last one is pretty good.
50 percent.
Yeah. I don't care. All right.
Things that don't matter. Lily de Ed
Well I really did read a lot of exploring the name hook. Oh
Ben that was a
Big game.
We did it one more episode coming up 26 of March.